schools by their very structure are
preparing kids for some sort of
authoritarian lifestyle I'm Sheldon
Richmond I'm editor of the Freeman the
magazine of the foundation for economic
education separate school and state
which was the title of my first book is
the idea that the state has no business
being involved in education thomas
Hodgkin who was I think a great
libertarian early 19th century said a
children would be better uneducated then
be educated by their rulers and of
course that's not really the choice we
face educational I think would proceed
just fine without the state but if
that's the choice then I would still
take education without the rulers the
state has always used education for dr.
nation purposes schools by their very
structure are preparing kids for some
sort of authoritarian lifestyle they
tell you what to study more or less
there may be sometimes scope for some
choice when the bell rings you stop what
you're doing you get up and move to
another room another subject maybe you
still want to spend a little more time
on the first subject but no the bell
rang kind of stick with the schedule
this is the way the early school
pioneers are the so-called common school
pioneers beginning with Horace Mann and
those people talked about we can find
statement after statement about how
children are wax children are plastic
children aren't dough to be needed on
the social kneading board at first
children are as identical as Ford's
I have three children and they were
they're not identical in any way except
they all you know our strong libertarian
through it sort of closed in that way
but that wasn't not the result of
indoctrination I'm proud to say it's
just sort of osmosis there you know we
heard and read and and met people and
absorbed it we never sat them down and
said okay now time for our daily reading
from human action or or Atlas Shrugged
or anything of that sort
I have been a critic of what's kind of
had taken the brand name of school
choice obviously out for choice in
education but school choice has come to
mean vouchers and charter schools where
parents are given more options and this
is supposed to present competition to
the public schools and and everything's
supposed to get better I am skeptical
about all this first of all I think it's
it's still a state solution the money
still comes from the taxpayers funneled
through the state and for most people
who are not libertarians they're gonna
see that as quote public money and I
think they're going to be open to the
argument that public money should not go
to quote unaccountable institutions
unaccountable schools but accountability
to to whom I want accountability to
parents that's what you get when they
control the money under vouchers and
charters you're going to get
accountability to some governmental
authority I mean there are cases where
charters have been revoked not because
the parents thought it was a lousy
school but because the chartering
Authority said you're not living up to
the Charter whatever the mission is
specified in the Charter and to me
that's not a free system if that if that
can happen and until you break the
financing link I don't think you're
going to get really what we want to get
the question of course arises how will
poor people get educated if if there's
not the cross subsidy which is what
happens when the government is paying
for it by taxing people we have a lot of
new stories to tell about that James
Tooley has done marvelous work in Africa
and Asia about some of the poorest
places on earth where there are a
for-profit private schools that poor
people go to so somehow they've been
able to begin to figure this out in
places that are much poorer than any
place in the United States there's also
the obvious answers of philanthropy you
know there were charitable foundations
there always been always been wealthy
people interested in education this
happened in the nineteenth century when
there was no income tax to take a
deduction from so they just did it from
the love of education and the love of
helping poor kids get an education we
see it some of it today I think we'd see
a lot more of it if the state were not
involved in schooling and I just think
that's not the problem that people
believe it is I think what would happen
after a while in a free environment is
that you see combinations hybrids really
a home of what we think of as
traditional homeschooling right the kids
sitting around the kitchen table with
the one of the parents or both of the
parents and some community mixing I mean
you see it today yeah I live in Central
Arkansas and my kids were still of
school age they were essentially
homeschooled oh and although more in the
unschooling mode of John Holt I'm John
Holt develop this idea unschooling and
this newsletter is called growing
without schooling and it was meant there
was no strict curriculum but at the same
time once a once a week a couple of
hundred kids would get together and and
they would have classes where in things
that maybe individual parents felt that
they weren't expert enough to to teach
so they it was a pooling of resources by
a lot of families and then either some
of the parents did have the expertise
and therefore could could teach to a
whole bunch of children or they even
bring in someone they knew who wasn't
maybe a parent of any of the kids there
but knew something about some subject I
gave it an eleven eleven week course on
introduction economics was just
essentially introduction to Austrian
economics and I had kids from six to
sixteen and they loved it they loved it
all the ages because these were bright
kids they were precocious and if there
were no rules being imposed by the state
I think we people would stumble uneven
new ways of doing things that's the
thing we got to keep it open-ended
we need to do what John jus joseph
priestley advised for education and he
said for all of the arts namely we have
to allow for trial and error and
experimentation and as you put it
complete liberty and even Caprice I love
the phrase that's what we need we need
to have an open end so people can try
things and fails it'll fail quickly and
something else we try